greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by zip recruiter you're hiring every
business needs great people and a better
way to find them and something better
than posting your job online and just
praying for the right person to see it
it's not gonna work all right
does it prakruti learns what you're
looking for and identifies the people
with the right experience and invites
them to apply to your job in fact 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiting get
a quality candidate through the site in
just one day you can't beat that so do
me a favor businesses of all sizes trust
rip recruiter for all their hiring needs
so right now the church family can get
zip recruiter for free gratis nothing oh
gods that's right free just go to zip
recruiter comm slash Church that's zip
recruited comm slash Church zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
number two I know you're looking to get
healthy everybody's looking to do
something go to Hahnenkamm right now and
check out the great line and supplements
from the protein powder to the [ __ ]
for shroom tech communes I took before I
got on that Southwest flight I'm not
concerned that that Japanese guy kept
sneezing behind me anymore
because I took four of those [ __ ]
shrimp deca meals and I'm tip-top Magoo
I got off the plane and had a little
acai bowl and then I went in froze at
chemotherapy for three [ __ ] minutes
cry out there right whatever the [ __ ] it
is u.s. Merapi so if you live in the
valley please go to us cryotherapy tell
them I sent you and go freeze for three
minutes and 15 [ __ ] seconds I suggest
you put on heaven and hell by Black
Sabbath and throw punches to your
[ __ ] can't take it no more go to
aadat calm right now press in church BAM
and get 10% off
you ought to deliver right to your house
whether it's the m4s protein which has
now called something different but try
the Mexican chocolate Mexicans don't
[ __ ] around especially on a Cinco de
Mayo go to alikom right now stay black
kick that [ __ ] meal Lee what's
happened you bad [ __ ] Monday
morning feeling good if you came out to
the sold-out shows in Tempe thank you
very much
I appreciate it the weird thing about
that club as I started there as an MC in
98 and
you go back 20 years later in your head
learning your songs out the [ __ ] room
what up I even got banned from there for
a year you got banned and now you're
back in the Tempe improv for a year with
Danny Murr comedy club bands never last
God rest his soul that creepy
[ __ ]
Danny Murr was a jealous God did you
ever he worked for Danny burnout exile
him now
when we first when I first moved out way
that Tempe improv was the premier improv
like you just didn't work Tempe like you
launder your never worth it like you had
to be recommended and recommended and
recommended but you had to be
recommended by coke fiends cuz his
favorite comics with coke fiends or
anybody that was a celebrity he would
mooch up for so the guy that owned Tempe
was an a a guy like the guy that really
owned the Klan wasn't alcoholics
anonymous guy who made it up all he had
bought the club where he was a drinker
and now that he was the president of AAA
of Arizona ah so he didn't let you drink
on stage he didn't want nothing like
that he wasn't self food so the club was
really weird the older was so the
general manager posed as the older and
he lost very Eric Griffin we talked
about it this week we saw the decline
like he was just a club guy that really
can't he knew how to book good comedians
he booked a good feature he knew Han uh
you know not put a dirty act together
with a clean I he there's no a bunch of
[ __ ] but then he lost his mind and he
loved Joe Rogan so every time I would go
down and he would be in my hair time
they were Rogen's go on a trek afterward
yeah that would tell him Danny he don't
want you around cuz Danny would do coke
ah this is Ben Grogan didn't get high at
all the heat of the you understand that
concept and he was all that guy creeps
me out look at his jaw how he was his
jaw and [ __ ] and I was thinking one that
we all went out and we were in
Scottsdale at a club and then Joe was on
fear factor so we were talking to the
who's that when I that's my long this is
the how long woman or that Club who was
the chick that was married to Tito Ortiz
the porn star
jameson jenna jameson lived in Tempe and
Phoenix or something at the time and she
was there with her then-husband at this
club with us Danny I think Ari and we
they let us stay at the club a little
while longer where everybody got out we
got out some kid took a bunch ecstasy
and didn't wait for the valet he got the
car and he ran over the valet
unlike three other kids so we walked out
and I just remembered this we walked out
of there and bodies were all over the
night somebody had thrown a brick at the
windshield stop the car and the kid was
bleeding from his [ __ ] head the cops
were there that had the crime scene up
it was [ __ ] crazy like this is Pepe's
a crazy [ __ ] place but I'm hot but
eventually Danny Murr lost his mind he'd
lost the club but then they reopened it
and the owners of this club one of them
is Joel and it's interesting that I was
there at the improv the Miami improv of
my Joel started Mike even came to the
club this weekend he goes you've been in
in a while man yeah 27 [ __ ] years and
how long you been doing this man since I
mean for real since 2003 no [ __ ] yeah
when I met you you had just yeah I just
we're doing it for years remember yeah
yeah I just you know I okay when I I
took like a comedy class when I was like
22 and then I started to go to open mics
a little bit but like not I wasn't
really trying to do it and then it just
you know it was a pipe dream that's why
I thought I just didn't have it at that
time and then it was until eight years
later that I was like okay I really want
to do this that's when I started going
over mics every day and really trying to
make it what did you do for those eight
years well I was man I was going to
school I was working I did I didn't know
what my life was gonna be I thought I
just thought oh you know when I was born
and raised in LA in LA so you're born
and raised in this environment it's
different when you from someplace else
and you see the dream and you think I'm
gonna work to get there I grew up here
so you know you go to a comedy club and
you go how do you get onstage there was
no mentors there was nobody trying to
help you there was nobody trying to tell
you how to do it anything like that so
you know I just
I needed to be older to like figure out
like okay I got to build relationships I
gotta like you know cultivate
relationship it's interesting you say
that because I start working with Joey
six seven years ago and I was like I'm
message Joey because I was a stand-up
fan but I never thought I wanted to do
it and then now six months ago so I
started doing open mics and every once
in a while I'll kick myself almost I go
I should have started six years at what
where would I be but I don't think I'd
be ready like do you think lad that you
way to those eight years no you know
people always say shouldn't have regrets
but I don't feel like that I feel like
you're what ever would you regret pushes
you to work harder wherever you're at
now like maybe you say well I shouldn't
have done that I don't believe in oh you
everything happens for a reason
no I'm just making up for it that's all
right you know I just knew what I just
fast-tracked at that point cuz it was
like when I was going to open mics Jamie
Kennedy was going to open mics and
living on people's couches I went to an
open mic with Jim Gaffigan I went to
open you know all these people so you
cut to like eight years later and I'm
looking at all these people that are
like wow look everybody's doing it what
why did I stop so instead of thinking
like oh my god what am I gonna do it
made me go oh I got really bust my ass
now when you what was going on through
your mind those eight years were you
watching Comedy Central
no I was like you know it I wasn't I
really wasn't like when you go into the
movie I was going to the movies exactly
I was watching like and the thing that I
always remember the thing that really
clicked in me was I watching Raw like
Eddie Murphy's raw like that was really
the thing that I looked at and I was
like oh man that's the first time I
really thought I think I want to do that
but I didn't know what to do I don't
know where to go so that's why I took so
long to find feeling when you're
helpless
yeah man as a helpless dude okay i'ma
tell you even better than that is when I
first I took a comedy class taught by
sandy shore by the way Mitzi's uh
daughter rest in peace to Mitzi and you
know the showcase was at the Comedy
Store and it was like the end of the
class graduation you know it was in the
oh our and I did this you know um and I
knew I had it I knew I had the bug right
then and there you know just that that
thing of like the whole crowd laughing
at you you know I was like oh man I love
this
after that I didn't know what to do like
literally right after I cuz they rolled
the show so let's say the seven o'clock
show was our graduation and then they
kept a crowd there and then they started
the real show and it was like Mencia
went up first you know and I remember
watching and seeing I'm thinking oh I
think I could do this cuz at the time he
wasn't you know who he was and he just
he was doing Taco Bell jokes and things
like that but he was dynamic you know I
mean so I thought what year is this Tom
and it must have been 90 something you
know for yeah and like 94 95 because he
cuz he brought up Chris Tucker you know
he had just so Def Jam and all that was
going on - you know this was like around
that time so he brought up man see it
goes up first and then he brings up
Chris Tucker and I remember watching
Chris Tucker and thinking I don't think
I can do this because he just like
forced a nature on stage at that time
you know so I don't know what to do I
just do I didn't know what to do it
that's the helpless feeling just sitting
there thinking okay well how do I get on
that show and this you have no idea
there's no blueprint there's no you know
there's no Learning Annex class you know
how'd it get on the main room stage
nothing love that kind of [ __ ] you know
yeah and I just figured it out I just
started going to open mics I went to the
the the the long beach the Queen Mary
they had a comedy club at the Queen Mary
they had this open mic called Marv's and
Mary's on Washington to do the own he
loved comedy so he would have like a
every night in a week he would have two
or three open mikes and then I just
started to go on all these places there
was Canoga ball there was all these
little coffee houses some of them you
had to pay for it was I just kept doing
it and that's how I realized you know
how you get work you get your peers to
think you're funny cuz they're the ones
that get you work I just did that
Queen Mary gig like two months ago
that's a different okay that's a new it
back to the end it was on but it was
crazy called laugh is hope but yeah and
then you just start that's how you start
doing it so I'm went from the Long Beach
then I went to the Ice House annex show
I was doing that for a little while and
then from the annex show I went to the
haha you know had to win Terry over at
the haha
and then I started doing arrows hosting
and doing a bunch of shows and then from
there I went to the comedy store to try
to showcase I had my first showcase
Mitzie didn't even look at me she didn't
even talk to me when I got offstage past
Jay Davis that night too by the way so I
wanted to kill myself
she passed Jay Davis on the night i
showcase with him
and she passed jay davis I look back on
and I think that was like a way to
motivate me and that motivated just [ __ ]
out of me so it was like a year and a
half later I got another so case but in
that time I was going to trying to get
into the Laugh Factory The Improv and I
was working those big clubs trying to
get into those big clubs you know and so
then I was doing the belly room show and
then in a Comedy Store and then I
finally got my real showcase it was in
the main room on one of those bringer
shows they had and they were doing
showcases during that and she was they
had her sitting at her booth you know
and she still she was starting to be ill
at that time you know and the only words
Mitzi has ever said to me as I got
offstage in there and they're walking in
her through the hallway to the kitchen
she stops she looks at me and she says
you was funny and then walked away and
that's the only word she's ever spoken
to me and then Tommy came up to me like
wow you know you were passed you know
she passed you and then I had to go do
the belly room for a solid year
before I got like made a paid regular
like I said once you get there now it's
a complete different story
totally yeah because you just thought
like I told one Smits he died is like a
little tribute thing uh-huh
and they really that weekend there was a
whole week of thought like like Ari
called me and so I'm coming back from
Australia because she might die in that
whole week I started thinking about how
important Mitch he was and my heart and
my development on my own you know I'm
not gonna lie to you
you know her passing me made me stay
here I was ready to leave yeah and she
passed me and now I'm with how what are
you doing yeah weird that once you get
past your happiest [ __ ] but now you get
thrown into this thing that you're
really not ready
not never ready for it you're never
ready for then you're looking at the
lineup and you're thinking then there's
not as a new challenge I remember being
on the lineup looking at the Ori lineup
and being like oh well I'm going up at
12 I don't want to go up at 12 then it's
like oh this is the Strunk
this is like it never ends that's what I
knew it never ended ever ends
you know you're like okay so now I got
to go up now I got a fight to get into
like wit wood how do you do that and
then you realize it actually has nothing
to do with the Comedy Store it actually
has to do with what you do with your
career you know and it's like so that's
why I was like okay so I got to go to
other things you know you know the
commercial agents and acting and all
this other stuff and in combination with
working yourself through you know
getting better at comedy it's gonna get
you those two things go they go together
who is your biggest who did you have to
follow that every time you followed on
the drive you want to take the call and
crash it into the building because you
knew you when I go die you know what it
was Dahmer era oh and the black dude
with dreadlocks I think of his name from
the time he's not around anymore he's a
solid dude he wasn't that guy that he
would do prints
the guy remember that guy no no this guy
didn't play a dog and he would just go
up then do straight stand-up but it was
ferocious you know what it wasn't like
that for me you know what it really
wasn't like that it was like I just
because at that time too Tommy had just
taken over so he was just trying to fix
the lineup you know like his as much
[ __ ] as people give him I mean if there
was a short time that he did you know he
was doing work you know to change the
culture of the place and get and get
people in there and really take the
thoughtfulness to the lineup and all
that kind of stuff look you know was he
like I don't know if Tommy was racist or
anything like that I don't know he just
maybe he's insensitive and you know
whatever he was but I thought there was
like a method to his madness and so at
that particular time and I never thought
I never it wasn't like that because
those guys weren't there anymore
there wasn't a big guy at the store when
I was coming through
it was just Giancarlo and Bret Ernst and
Sebastian and these people and I never
thought anybody was like I never thought
I loved those guys but I had confidence
in myself where I was like I felt like
the enemy was did this lineup is the
enemy
Tommy was the enemy trying to hold me
back so I was like no I'm gonna work and
I always had just you know delusional
confidence about myself that I didn't
think any of these dudes were funnier
than me so you got into a store about
2007 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what I wasn't really around five or
seven yeah
and this was before I even got anything
like I got into the storm started doing
spots and then I got on TV it was weird
you know it's uh
when Tommy first got into the first off
I was there with ten different [ __ ]
down on board yeah Duncan everybody else
and it was crazy how Dan the bold crazy
when you have direct contact in those
days with Mitzi and Haiti calls a day
yeah but they all ended up going crazy
and they were all little white like you
had my favorite with Scott day I really
like Scott - Scott day was the guy that
was there when I became a regular Scott
they got it
Scott they've really had it what is a
certain type of personality yeah he had
to be to deal with these people always
coming at you you know I'd give me spot
can I get a spot you know weird you have
power
it's a weird how you have to have a
certain personality to deal with that
you know but he was gay
oh well they enough so he's gay handsome
and he [ __ ] just was a great guy but
I saw an argument and him he would hang
at the store cuz he would drink so he
would hang at the storm watch the comics
and talk to different comics and I still
remember a certain argument he had with
dice one night how he was sticking you
know I liked Scott
and then Scott quit I don't know who
then Cori Cuomo repent replaced Scott
day and that was completely crazy I
don't remember any of these dawg Corey
was Freddy Soto's he's his wife so she
started booking it but then it seemed
like all the brothers would go there to
see Eric Griffin but Freddy soda would
be on
laughter Eric Oh before Eric he was
saying like it was just it's trying to
get biased and people started to know it
Oh Danny Kelly was there for a while
Danny Kelly was a phone guy but one day
they just made him and poor Danny Kelly
was awful trying to be a comic yes yes
some saying yeah so loud and he started
give himself like 15 spots you know and
it got out of hand he shut up one day he
had a box on his [ __ ] desk I said
they replaced him with Duncan and then
Duncan didn't want to do that Duncan bit
it was you an alphabetical order towards
oh my god yeah then when they did the
reality show Duncan got out Duncan got
out before the reality show I remember
that and then finding the store ending
the store and then Tommy came with him
now if they were to do minding the store
now is the time to do it for real now is
the time but if I'll say that it's
different not bad different because
they're what was taken away from the
comedy store with just new Regine what
was taken away is this idea that you
were a part of a club and you had to
earn your way to get something no matter
what you had you know and now it's not
like necessarily like that like if
you've got stuff going on you're gonna
get into rotation and you're gonna be in
and it's like and it's like you know and
that's fine too but like if you come
from the old way like for me I remember
having to do an hour I had to do a year
in the belly room you know I had before
I could do all our spots you know now
it's just not like that and some of the
new people that come in they don't have
the same respect or reverence for the
place because they didn't have to go
through that you know and so it's not
bad it's just different so if you from
the old school you got to wrap your
brain around that but I feel privileged
I feel very uh it's I feel very lucky to
be a part of what's happening at the
Comedy Store right now and I think in
ten years ago look back and be like man
remember when that's that you know the
go the new golden years of the comedy
straw right now you know so that credit
to Adam you know he get for what he's
doing it's sensational that I walk
I was like that this place I'll never be
a regular here like this will never work
for me you know look at these [ __ ]
people in there and when I first got
into the count still my gonna lie that
you know I put my heart and soul into it
like that was all that was it that's all
I had that's it when this is all you
have like that remember when they told
the Richard Gere you gotta leave and he
said I got nowhere else to go nowhere
else didn't that that death that's
exactly I was homeless I would take
showers in the main room and 9:15 I
would bring I would drive to the comedy
store and take a shower at 9:15 the main
room and then go back at a correlate and
take another shower on the back I towel
shampoo the whole thing I would do
laundry laundry mat and sleep in the
[ __ ] car I mean that was the Comedy
Store to me I ate there and [ __ ] you
know if the waitresses got food and
mooched the half a sandwich I ate two
cherries
that's why I haven't I'm weighing 400
pounds I would eat those maraschino
cherries like a [ __ ] only in
America you could be homeless and still
in that's fat being yeah America how was
eating those Wendy's dollar menu Wow
four or five hours you give the bowl of
chili you get the jr. whatever that's it
you know the one special boys walk then
it just clicked huh you know 15 bucks a
set Philippe bass bars or Willie Barcena
forties Rudy Moreno $50 about the
converse a scene I started doing knows
yes and that's a whole really [ __ ] the
only gigs that paid with a Latino gaiety
no good only gigs a day oh my god you
have to go to like weird places and
Bobby will come over to you and be like
thanks for coming Missy bucks yeah Bob
chef Garcia used to have authorized me
and they give you a taco yeah yeah
[ __ ] pipe and a [ __ ] bag of weed I
mean it was like this [ __ ] Latin fly
that's how I got in first my first TV
credit was my second TV Carter has piled
my first TV credit was actually night
call it was this show on the Playboy
channel it was like it was like the it
was like The Tonight Show for porn
chicks you know and I did a stand-up set
on there and then my second one would
but you know how I got that you know I
got payaso
Darren Carter the party starter you know
Darren he hit me up was like yo can you
come with me to this gig in like deep
Whittier like it was like deep in the
hood someplace right the Latino hood you
know and he goes come with me if he just
wanted me to come with him so we can get
the carpool lane on the freeway so you
can drive no carpool lane so I go I do a
set I just happen to be going up in
front of Alex Reymundo
and Alex says to me cuz that's the only
reason why he watched me cuz you know
you don't really watch people until you
unless you going up after them then you
might sit and watch Alex come up to me
and says hey I'm about to do this show I
think you'd be good on it let me talk to
my guys and then you could we're doing a
show at the improv you know and I went
did that show at the improv that's when
I met Scott Montoya and all these people
and they were like alright they booked
me on the payaso comedy slam what did
you think at first I thought well I
didn't have anything so I thought why
I'm gonna be on Showtime I thought it
was gonna be this big thing to his
credit the way he put it together then
was the way you should put things
together we did two shows you know what
I mean if he was doing it now he
wouldn't have done two shows it would
have been if it was two shows it would
be like 10 comics you know what I mean
and it just wouldn't Akane out I thought
they got the best out of it by doing two
shows and combining and that's how they
should do all those things but anyway I
thought it was great then we're at this
big 900 seat theater and it's San
Bernardino and all these people and I'm
like wow this is amazing look what I'm
doing a TV thing and I thought I was
gonna be great and then I thought well
this the potential for a tour for this
too and like you know all these great
comics on the lineup you know Johnny
Johnny Sanchez and you know you know
like Joey Medina and Alex were mundo and
you know all these people all these up
and comers and you know I thought oh
this is good and then what happened we
did one show a day Indian casino and
that's the last we heard of payaso
comedy slam I when they approached me
they had been talking with like a year
that he was going to do something the
guy kept coming up to the store and old
guys oh yeah yeah yeah what was his name
get what is now like
and then they made an offer and when
they said Showtime on my liver do you
know how many [ __ ] things I shot over
the do you have any idea totally totally
different places in our career at that
time eight hundred dollars a thousand
bucks
three fifty to shoot a special that
we're gonna sell to Showtime or PBS you
know many of those deals I had I could
count them on flights amazing I wish I
had an abacus like that's how many
things the same set for all know you
just people contact you and go loca
we're putting the show together we shall
want it to haha I'll never forget that
was the most embarrassing thing I was
ever involved because I was cheering for
it not to air like that I just wanted
the money that's it I did a movie like
that yeah you just can't [ __ ] the money
you don't care if it's fat you want it
to fail you don't want nobody to see you
in this you're like I hope nobody ever
sees this there's a guy that shot me I
swear to God
maybe ten years ago we did a special and
a theater in Hollywood this guy went all
out borrowed eighty thousand from his
grandfather oh no the whole thing as
he's given me the money I'm like you
poor bastard he's like yeah I got a
cousin the one in on Telemundo special
and all this [ __ ] he [ __ ] sold it he
went on bro he called me a year later
dawg
can I have a mission to put on YouTube
[ __ ] no [ __ ] you and [ __ ] no you're not
putting that on YouTube I was prepared
for I mean it has been so many of those
people approached me over the years so
we'll be doing the payaso slam yeah
cocaine same thing same thing it was
like that back then oh yeah I know that
bad that was the tail end oh that was
the tail end of the demon by didn't go
to the party that's what I don't catch
my drug dealer we closed the trouble you
went but you did that payaso who did
this you you were at that gig we did at
that Indian casino
come on yeah man remember that gig we
did at the Indian casino no oh what yeah
you were oh you were gone you were yeah
that you don't even remember
No yeah man we went to uh I gotta
remember we're like deep deep in the
mountain it was something and the guy
called me Gabriel I don't even remember
that one the guy was so drunk he's like
look who it is it's Gabriel remember and
remember Johnny didn't come because he
was at a Funeral
he says he was at a Funeral
but we did anyways we only did one show
I know you were there cuz I remember you
were talking [ __ ] in the green room
that's where I remember specifically you
just were like going off about different
things it was so when I shop aaaah so I
shot payaso like anything else I shot
like this ain't gonna go nowhere yeah
like this ain't no way I'm just gonna do
a fine cook til today I [ __ ] regret
it well for me I just I it was like I
say it was my first real major like oh
it's I said no know what I mean I don't
think I regret what I did I wish I was a
dress better
oh that gosh I would have prepared
myself for it I didn't take it seriously
I didn't show up for the wraparound I
didn't want to be involved I didn't care
and this is the regrets that you have is
a comment from time to time huh but I
had to call Montoya and actually tell
him I'm sorry for my behavior
oh wow I wish I would have done it
differently I would have been a
different comic today because I didn't
take it serious that sound like I sat
down with a notebook and worked on this
set right weeks and right right right
I just went there was a night after
Thanksgiving do you remember I don't
remember it was it we shot that either
the night after Thanksgiving or like
before Thanksgiving I think was a
weekend those who go ahead into
something yeah I told him it better
being cash I don't have time for checks
I like time for a check so you better
put yard sticks in their hasty y'all
ready yeah are you using all of these
years ago Rudy gave me a check that
bounced and after that I won't take
checks just give me the check come on
one time by me I love Rudy now I love ya
he was the one that he was that he gave
me that some of the best spots I've ever
when I was first coming up looking in
this comedy game I was sitting in the
Tempe improv and they were talking about
that the week before DL Hughley had been
yeah yo Glee was DL Hughley the first
time I stepped onstage mm-hmm
like DL Hughley was already big 25 years
ago like he liked the journeys people
have had everybody has a different
journey you know he DL Hughley was DL
Hughley
I thought DL Hughley do something I
never saw any other human being do he
got a standing ovation as an MC dan that
Jam standing ovation as an MC just
destroyed the room like whoever had to
follow him god bless his soul just
leveled the room DL Hughley was dead
before me the week before this is a
phenomenal journey this this comedy like
yeah yeah yeah yeah for real it's a
phenomenal journey the first 10 years
suck depending on how you look at it
yeah and it sucks depending on the
effort you put in it but everybody has a
different journey so you can't judge
yourself it's like you've said yeah you
did it for two years then you [ __ ]
pull off your mind one day it's such a
[ __ ] weird calling yeah but you could
have been dentist a doctor a lawyer you
chose something that is the hardest
thing in the world it's so weird because
once the best fruit that the addiction
of the comic mind is the bearing of the
fruit the little fruit Mannix guess what
last night at Rudy's room I did 38
minutes problem yeah yeah I know Jemaine
I'm saying yeah but were the first time
you had to do that long so long set
somebody [ __ ] I remember I remember
for me I had to go to I did Tribble runs
you ever did a triple run come on yes I
had to do yes I you know I was doing
these 30 minutes you know I was like wow
first time I did 30 minutes I what
places he goes oh man come on Billings
my most what they look at you like in
Missoula and all the Montana ball in
Bozeman in all these places it was great
right I remember my first time ever
doing a row gig was the first one was I
went out to like San Marcos and near San
Diego that was my first
one of those type Booker's and I was
like oh this is great
and so now my first out-of-town gig is a
is a trouble run and I have to go - what
was that uh Montana someplace in Montana
and I had to fly to Utah to meet the
headliner this guy named Scott Bennett
okay and I get there and he's all like
yo man my license is uh my license is
you know expired whatever it was your
restricted license so you got Drive you
know so I'm driving his car you know
from Utah to Montana with with his dog
he has a dog right and we hit the places
dispatch the car is jam-packed
you don't I mean so I'm driving but I
was I loved every second of it
and we got to this little town and we
was at the Holiday Inn and the shows in
the bar you know and I go down early to
look no one's in there and I'm thinking
okay two people gonna show up you know
this shows shows about to start
there's like 12 people in this bar and
I'm like what's going on and then a guy
looks at music you ready to start and I
was like okay you know and he's like all
right here we go he goes on stage he's
like are everybody just a few
announcements before we start remember
the dart tournament you just sign up for
that on Thursdays and we got karaoke or
whatever you know and he's going on he
goes all right dude comics here from LA
names Eric you know here we go and
that's how I got brought on stage for my
first out-of-town gig in front of like
1213 rednecks in Montana here we go
and I got on stage and I just I was like
I made it you know I loved every second
of that hundred dollars I made that
hotel room hold and we traveled there
were night yeah we traveled like 500
miles every single day for a week you
know and it was no rhyme or reason to
the gigs anyway either so it might be
Bozeman's here in the next closest city
might be a something else but no we had
to drive past that place to go to some
faraway place and then drive back and it
was snowing and it was just might be to
go to Miles City Montana which is way up
there it was like I that was my first
experience on the road and I thought
okay does he get better I was like damn
this is innocently triple week's agenda
door um not too many because I did a few
but not too many
I'd also get Pat Wilson remember Pat
Wilson
she thought that a run was the third and
ninth and the twelfth she thought that
that was a run yeah so what am I
supposed to do between the third and an
eyeball in Seattle at that time they had
you had Pat Wilson you had another chick
that she's dead god rest her soul she
was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and yeah and you had the chick from
Portland Oregon the chubby chick and
then you had yes I love Richards
what's her faces and she's still a lot
duh I know the chubby chick partly cuz
she had like she would do gigs in Tahoe
Tahoe and [ __ ] yeah yeah when you book
the third the 7th and the 12th is
because you would call the other way
they didn't say hey I'm doing runs for
Pat Wilson and she'd go what date she
gonna be in and then she would fill
those in and then you would fill the
comedy underground on Monday for the
open mic right right and then you would
that so it would be eight or ten days Oh
Seattle that's that yeah no please go
from and then you called John Fox Ninh
your weekend Bellingham I'm all the way
by the Canadian border he had a bunch of
[ __ ] all [ __ ] he had these
little [ __ ] bars you would do and
you didn't you wonder like what's going
on to a hotel no hotel you're driving
and so at that time I thought this was
great this is $100 in the hotel and who
was the mid who was the mid mid country
guy CW Kendall was Texas but there was
somebody that would be like right next
and there was when I was coming up there
was a company that were very good they
were very good to me I forget what their
name was I sent him a tape and they made
me a co-headlining I'm a right off the
bat I remember the first time I did that
I remember the first time I did I ate
dick oh my god first week with them on
the road and they were as nice as can be
a beaut my Anna was my first hour-long
gig for Tribble I had to do an hour you
think I had an hour please I didn't have
an hour I was like how the [ __ ] am I
gonna do this hour but III powered
through it that's when I knew I had to
take it a little
more serious that was like when I was
like okay I gotta take this serious you
know I was doing all these things at a
commercial age and I booked a few
commercials that's why I stayed afloat
and then like I said when I got the
payaso comedy slam that was 2006 then in
2008 I booked live at Gotham you know
live at Gotham is when I got my first
agent TJ mark Walder mark marker he was
my first he booked me from that and then
he's the one that like on his reputation
got me out doing like low pay headlining
gigs and then from there is when you
know that's when everything started to
happen so how many years into this were
you both when you started doing Road
gigs well for me I started doing road
games like but see these aren't great
Road gigs yeah oh yeah so it was like a
year and a half I was out I was out
doing triple runs you know I needed a
new cuz I got a show shotgun here there
but I I know I couldn't make it in LA
though I know yes see I knew in LA like
I don't know why people come to LA like
these guys that don't just started doing
crazy crazy thing and then they get
upset about their spoil because let's
say you a comic you live in Tempe okay
you're a comic you live in a live in
Phoenix Arizona Tempe and then like here
comes Joey Diaz is coming into town and
you get to open you get to be MC so you
think that's regular you think it's
regular to be in front of 600 people
every night you think oh this is what
comedy is like [ __ ]
no it's not it's your it's in LA it's
the open mic in front of eleven people
it's the belly room at you know one
o'clock in the morning if you even have
the opportunity to get into oh are you
going I'm super late when you first
start you first get into these things
1:15 and they don't even know how to
deal with that they're just like there's
only 11 people here how can I perform a
front of 11 see that's what that taught
me how to perform for 10 people AP
exactly people exactly I never forget a
story that I went to Houston and I did a
show in fact Joel was saying he goes do
you remember Easter Sunday we did a show
on Easter Sunday wanted the Miami improv
that
I had 60 people in there and it will
start at 8:11 with a naked woman getting
up on stage and let me eat fruit off a
[ __ ] his [ __ ] was crazy but I learned
all those small people set from Mikami
story there's nothing happened one that
I'm gonna call at about 10:30 at night
and it's uh club over in Houston you
know I'll tell you something he goes now
I understand you guys from the store
because Johnny Sanchez who's here
tonight and we had there was a Houston
rocket playoff game so we only had 14
people I was gonna cancel the show he
said he would cancel it Joey
you know he's one of the best shows ever
seen in my life he does that's what you
guys get from the store yeah ma'am it's
he wouldn't put you through three years
a [ __ ] midnight in those days for me
it was following Paul Mooney see this is
what I'm talking about yeah you have
this idea of like this is even what I
don't know pales in comparison to what
you know like it's not even the same
kind of thing so now it's just a simple
like you know and the thing is like
sometimes it causes a thing like I
remember you know it's like like there's
a thing activist or it's like you know
you call if you're gonna be late and
then the next person goes and then you
go up after you know like these new
people come they don't even they don't
understand any of those kind of type of
things it's so it's just different you
know but like I say I remember coming up
and just I like that people I've had a
lot of bad situations with young comics
in LA because of the movement what they
expect to happen oh it doesn't drive me
crazy because I know the ropes I know it
needs to be done I didn't I know how
much time needs to be spent so you come
to me with any story and I know when
you're ready and when you're not do you
know I am because I know the timeframe
and I know the work ethic that needs to
go and then something else has to happen
you have to become it and that's a
complete level that's what happened to
you after those eight years when you
came back you be
coming you know that's a different
[ __ ] feeling you know what I was I
tell young comics I always say you know
you have to to know you could do this
you don't have to answer that to me this
is a rhetorical question you have to
with with you and whoever you believe in
they have you you have to believe this
is what you're meant to do and you don't
really feel that until you've gone
through some stuff like when you stop
worrying about when you stop feeling
like you're entitled to things people in
this business think that it's like a
deli where you take a number and you're
waiting for Hollywood to go number 75
and like yes my chance is my time to go
make it no it doesn't work like that
sometimes people skip the line sometimes
people take a long time sometimes people
get a chance and they fall right off
sometimes people work for a long time
before they get a chance there's no
right or wrong way you just gotta be
ready you have to know this is what
you're meant to do but see the young
comics in Los Angeles what happens is
that they mingle with guys like you and
I or other comics and they feel well how
come I'm not moving as fast as he's not
moving where if you developed in
Michigan you're not worried about a
[ __ ] headshot yeah yeah yeah no
worries about being seen in the coffee
shop there's so many variables that
aren't involved when you do comedy in
Boston per se or in Miami or New Orleans
or you're in Houston Texas per se
there's and things you don't even worry
about then you don't need to worry about
at that level do you know I'm saying
yeah at that level when you start
worrying about the three years why
should have a commercial agent no you
shouldn't you never [ __ ] trip will run
if you'll [ __ ] your pants in a [ __ ]
commercial audition you will [ __ ] your
[ __ ] pants I know when you're ready
for a come-on you'll know it when you go
up Danny and you're gonna audition and
you're [ __ ] read and you're handshake
you know how many times that happened to
me
at The Sopranos call back the third time
first he's allowed the hint you should
have heard it you thought it was a copy
you thought it was a [ __ ] hurricane
on CNN we know when you want to our
audition you have to have
do you to base you I even if I was loft
book I'd always have something to base
me and I was taught I can't tell you how
many are whether what's the world's met
then the other guy Rona crest she was
huge when I started when you got read by
Rona crass oh [ __ ]
that's like Clint Eastwood [ __ ] I
remember one time it was like a fan was
off in the room they could they kept
saying joy put the [ __ ] paper down
put it down put it down already and [ __ ]
you don't you know you you know how many
auditions you have to blow before you
know oh my god so it all works in unison
yeah if you really see it before you
book the commercial you had to go to
Butte [ __ ] and that half hour that you
didn't have you just earned that
commercial going to an acting class you
know it's crazy what the pattern is and
I hate when people try to move ahead of
it or you could do that's what people
want to do they want to skip you wanna
skip the line they want to get I've
tried that crazy because you're gonna
have to go back I always compare the
Pennzoil commercial from the 90s you can
either pay me now or you could pay me
later how many times The Last Comic
Standing did somebody win and they were
not a headliner they were put on the
road they did one good stint on the road
and then they disappeared because they
were not ready to headline but the
agents got greedy with them still put
them up how many stories have we heard
by now
going on I've been to Fame have you been
to clubs and I'm talking about how yeah
I can't bring I can't bring that person
you know they they want this and but now
it's to they busted it's done so even if
that show comes back and those people
gonna row don't the clubs know now
they're like well let's see let me see
who comes you know they really I see but
I always think they messed up in that
particular the NBC NBC did not have
enough respect for that show if they did
this could have been a different thing
like American Idol
what legitimizes American Idol is when
the person that wins goes on to do a
record contract and I saw
comes out so if your NBC and you have
the Last Comic Standing you're supposed
to take that person and throw them on a
sitcom make them a star
that's your net you can do is your
network give them a five episode arc on
Law & Order make them a star but they
just throw them to the wind oh we did
this thing and now it's over
so you America has been watching and now
that I well I thought that was you made
you made it seem like this was an
important thing that's where he messed
up that show could have still be going
on today it could be like a hit it could
be great for comedy if they would have
done that
like if the winner gets a development
deal and they had their own sitcom that
comes out that year you know Nicky Z
could have done that but nope they just
like they they canceled the show one
year before their final before the
finale they canceled the show so well
it's interesting because I'm at a place
at six months that even like 12 people
sounds exciting to me because I'm doing
it for all comics but you were talking
about people jump wanting to jump the
line but it's a weird industry where we
don't really have this information like
I understand that like it's a little
jumping the line but how are you really
supposed to know like I know I'm not a
headliner but why could I min my head
i'ma go maybe I could do a triple one
but you're like no you're at least a
year two away from a triple run well
I'll say there's no right or wrong way
it's all about the work ethic that you
put into it like times have changed now
in the old school heads got to remember
they've got to realize this like for
instance if somebody is on gotta
Instagram following and they and they've
done their little funny videos and
they've gotten millions of followers now
and they want to start doing comedy
that's their open mic now that's their
process to get on stage and it's valid
okay when people complain about
Instagram people or YouTube people I
always say they're just better at
Instagram than you if you were good at
Instagram you'd have a million followers
too so nobody wants to go to open mics
open mics suck but we had to because it
was the only way to get on stage now
there are numerous ways to get on stage
there are actors like Jeremy pivens who
decided I want to be a comic now so
because of his fame he don't have to go
through to open my process Julie you
know they decided for him
he's sexually harrassed brown eyes on
the road but either way
and again that's a mistake so we'd have
to go through this I'm gonna put a guy
who's crazy over [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
Road
exactly it's like my mother for years
whenever a player would [ __ ] up they son
to Miami really yeah the guy's got
enough problems living in them but you
can't stop snorting like a son to the
dolphin you're a [ __ ] genius I'm just
saying there's no right or wrong way to
do this thing let's what I'm telling to
you is that you just it's all about your
own work ethic so cuz the problem is
this you're gonna you might get an
opportunity and you have to be ready
being ready is putting a lot of time and
work in so when your agent calls and
says hey there's this audition for
such-and-such
when you get there you're not gonna be
out of your element you know and that's
what happened and that takes all the
practicing and all the time you put in
to hone your craft and and and know how
to deal in which situations performing
in front of five people and performing
in front of a thousand people and all
these different things are gonna lead
you to when you are in front of that
casting director you are ready that's
what happened to me when I when I got
workaholics
I remember the Audeo I was auditioning
Willie Barcena was there Johnny Sanchez
was there so I got the first call the
second call you know it did my I was
looking around the room and I was like
I'm not gonna get this cuz it was to do
from George Lopez show to do from Boston
Legal it was like all these guys Jay
Phillips was there he had just done Phil
will a Will Ferrell movie and I'm
looking around like I don't have [ __ ]
how am I gonna beat these people and I
just thought but I was ready I prepared
for that audition man I busted my ass on
that audition yeah my frie was working
on it with my friends I was making
choices and I went in there and I was
like bow they had to give it to me
so after that experience when I hear
people say oh I don't know if they're
looking for me I go don't think like
that but how did you learn I learned
that next so now anything I go on I feel
like oh I can book this I don't care
who's gonna remember this I'm the same I
don't even [ __ ] who was in the room dawg
I remember going to auditions just
getting in signing your name
around sitting down looking at his sheet
you're so insecure then you pop your
head up he just glazed across the room
and you see he was in the room with you
and the more you move your head the
harder your heart this guy was an ocean
to leaven this guy wasn't Rambo oh my
god what's he doing here he's on a
sitcom for eight years yeah yeah and
then you get the callback and now you're
in the room would even heavier hitters
like I haven't forget the callback for
uh for a while but the movie they made
about boxing the [ __ ] Nam the black
dude treed no way this was right before
the first strike in LA
oh sure that the first one reality show
is about the reality TV was about to
take over who went to jail displayed
oh well it's nicely slams did a movie
where he was a boxer in prison hmm oh
yeah okay well he was a boxer in prison
and I remember I got a call to be one of
the gangsters and Jesus Christ Irish
they put me through hell it was a in
those days there was a thing called the
pre-read in this town a [ __ ] pre-read
high-level casting people would just
make you them come in and talk to you mm
hi Eric what's your name with you like I
like spam that only better stand up for
food a favor read this for me and then
they would call your agent and make sure
you to read for the role
I started dead with this [ __ ] guy ham
his name was Ruben something he was
black he has his offices when I'm LaBrea
and Wilshire that tall building there on
the right-hand side they were all in
there in those days Rubin the chick the
cast the volleyball movie they were all
in there if you want and then dropped
off ten headshots you'd get a call in
three days because they were all in
there I would go into every 90 days and
just drop off headshots all 10 floors
and a different casting director so I
went in there he pre read me when I went
to that first [ __ ] read it was in
Hollywood then and they made like a nice
office with white people when they offer
you water and [ __ ]
you know those auditions or like that
now oh yeah you go off of people water
but usually going audition it'll offer
you [ __ ] yeah
that audition the first time I went to
read read they offered me [ __ ] water
I'm will [ __ ] my pants I think they
validated my parking yeah I was like oh
[ __ ] this is real and you walk in the
room and there's four [ __ ] guys and
they've all been in big movies the one
guy was the guy that [ __ ] he was the
sound of forget that read that was the
scary cuz I just saw seven the night
before it was on cable and I wanted the
next day and he's sitting there reading
for the same part I'm reading floor but
then something would happen and you want
me to tell you what started happening
yeah what's that
I bet you I feel the same way two things
happened I had to do halftime of a
Buffalo Sabres game one time oh [ __ ]
and I got booed so bad I got booed so
[ __ ] bad
fifteen minutes it was just horrible
like nothing to bring you back and then
I got made a regular at the store and
fees had to follow up all morning so
actually this is what would happened to
me I would go to those auditions walking
very insecure my little mafia suit I'm
walk-in sign-in you know sit down and
look at the sheet like I don't know what
I'm doing and then I popped my head up
and look around the room but I'd see
Frank Stallone as T Johnny roast beef
I'd see the guy that got freezer freezed
and The Sopranos I'd see all those guys
not ditions after a minute I know what
yeah this guy probably went to Juilliard
this guy studied with Johnny Bananas and
this guy studied with Johnny Gobots but
guess who the [ __ ] I am
number one I didn't have time on the
Buffalo Sabres game and number two I
follow Paul Mooney on a nightly and I
know for a fact none of these
[ __ ] in the room can do that
yeah man and that's when I started
booking where's that Tony Bennett you
were talking about I want to give some
shoutouts real quick to young runt
my brother Pat Shea who showed up in
Tempe with some hot chick that kept
trying to make videos not get the [ __ ]
off I want to give a shout out
- lieutenant Scott Smith tempies best
for coming to the show I want to give a
shout out to Pistol Pete
fer giving us the cover of this in a
single also Nick Becca
Adrian Valdez the Latin bastard Ken
riffey jr. and Herron and Ramirez thank
you [ __ ] for coming out to the
shows and having a great time and all
that [ __ ] and that's it
so did you take an acting class yeah I
did I took a class with this lady named
Janet al honty and she was great like
that Meisner like this old New York
Jewish lady you know she was a big woman
you know so she would sit in a chair you
know and she would sit back in her chair
like trying to be funny
stop trying to be funny you know she's
very MIT CSKA actually in terms of her
like how she attacked comedians you know
with the acne and I and I I love to
intellectualize things so like to me the
best part of acting class was not
actually doing it sometimes was watching
other people yes and then hearing the
notes and then really examining like I
was like damn they really this systems
this is something's going on here yes
you know and that was great like my
first real acting class I see a lot of
those people working today like the girl
Jamie Alexander she's on that show blind
spot she was in that class I remember
you know when I saw at the Laugh Factory
one night she was like started crying
she was like I remember our class
together and I was like wow again we've
come a long way I can people come a long
way so I think I think class is
important it was until I started doing
acting class and improv that I felt my
stand-up hopped my stand-up really like
cuz I understood that this was a this is
a problem I did I did a bunch of places
you know I did I took a class I took
this kind of like used to the extension
like comedy acting and improv and then I
did like what's the one and not UCB but
the one on Wilshire my Melrose there we
are we are rolling Groundlings okay I
did the first first thing of ground was
but I didn't continue cuz I always felt
like improv is a skill to make acting
and stand-up better not something that
should stand on its own to me it's you
know you know what I mean like I think
improv is like what
improv shows I'm always like I don't
want you know but the people that could
do that like at a high level that's
always very entertaining but I think
that is great for like when you do it
within like oh here's a movie situation
stand-up TV or a play or whatever
wherever that you know you're using that
skill to enhance another part of
entertainment but anyway actually I went
through a chapter of my career there was
like a two-year stint when I went to New
York I picked up a bad habit of talking
to the audience I picked up a very bad
habit it's a lazy habit you know who I'm
talking and I got good at it I got good
at happen it's not hard to be good at
that when you're a charismatic comedian
I I got really good at it everybody
thought it was always 5050 yeah it's
always a 50-50 show it's always like so
I would have 22 minutes of material and
I would Bank on 30 more of improv and I
would start in the middle or close at
the end yeah yeah yeah I went through
that phase where I forced myself because
when I was a house and see at the
boulder broker
it was the same mooches every week that
came into heat after a while you're like
we know your material five for a steak
and you got a comedy show with the steak
so it was the same [ __ ] 40 people
came in for steak night and then they
would stay to watch the comics and I was
the headliner so I would just do topical
jokes in those days I would just go
through the paper it's really weird when
I look at my journey and then I started
talking to the audience and that ended
in Seattle when I moved to Seattle
something goes you know lived everywhere
yeah somebody's dog you got to stop
[ __ ] talking to people because you're
good at it
don't get me wrong and the improvising
is good well once you move to LA it's
not gonna be winner for you and then I
stopped at the store I never [ __ ]
really talk to people never ever ever
especially cuz like you we're not
watching the whole show and now I don't
even consider [ __ ] doing it like now
that people paying to come see me I
wouldn't even take a chance and [ __ ]
improvise I'll throw a tagging if it's
appropriately sometimes you write
onstage and stuff
that so workaholics you benign but now
more than ever young I'm dying up here
yeah we started you know started
workaholic so that was from 2010 to let
we did seven seasons of that you know
this crazy character I enjoy it I I'm
always gonna look back with fondness of
being on the show that's like people's
favorite show
you know people still come up to me
today every day is like Montez you know
they love that show so that was great
but then to get this show this kind of
like meaty dramatic dark you know it
shows a different side of me and I I'm
really as very rewarding you know that's
why I need people to watch it so
hopefully if this this is Monday this is
gonna come out Monday you know hopefully
you watched Sunday night and if not get
on on-demand Showtime anytime and watch
I'm dying up here Sunday's 10 o'clock
starting this week Sunday's 10 o'clock
you already missed the first episode so
catch up no the first episode out like a
show to have a few weeks ago that was
just a premier premiere but tonight
there was Sunday night is the actual
like premiere for a night on a Showtime
yeah yeah yeah tomorrow night what
tonight tonight yeah yeah I'm confused
I'm happy that you act you I get you
enjoy it I do enjoy it I enjoy like you
know it's like people say to me do you
like acting or stand-up more and I think
I like them equally because they're
different you know I like taking
somebody else's work like you know this
this paint paint or words on the page
and then bring it to life there's
something great about that there's
something great about being in this like
a made up environment and you're like
creating something you know you're
making people feel things I love all
that you know it's funny I had a weird
thing this week
listen success Winston Churchill define
success is moving from area to area with
class and enthusiasm you know that's why
I knew I couldn't make it in the real
world as a human being I gotta [ __ ]
get up at eight
and do it you have to move around a
little bit I like that like switching
around I enjoy acting I enjoy stem but
they all have like I enjoyed podcasting
I don't want to do a [ __ ] podcast I
know exactly what you're saying it's
like you know I love doing stand-up I
love being on the road but then there's
a time when I'm like I'm at this Airport
again again yeah man I like the house I
won't go out back to the back no yeah no
more back to back weeks when I don't
want to go out and take pictures of
people or I don't want to do little
things yeah I don't want to be yeah I
know I'd rather go out every other week
be a hundred percent they oh they
deserve that money they did not err of
my game I don't want to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I like that I come in and
I book a show for two days and I'm not
talking negatively about the show
it's just aspects of acting that uh it's
the other stuff you know I like the
freedom of podcasting I've loved doing
this was my thing since day one because
I got nobody looking over my shoulder
yeah yeah yeah we could say whatever the
[ __ ] we want we could book what the [ __ ]
we want you know we could really get a
couch right now and get some pose up in
this [ __ ] stream this yeah and
whoever you know thank God I'm not doing
coke and doing a [ __ ] cuz I've been
doing a podcast Norton cold the only
people with good if they had podcast
just bring the video like this is you
you know wonder why the cops are here
can you imagine to come late the mad
periscope er yeah just pop it up
everything you'd have two million
followers you'd run commercials on the
periscope for [ __ ] coke dealers you
should call me now 1-800 this fall will
disconnect in 30 seconds never
understand when people like put people
send you these snapchats like all these
Morgan hog fans will semi snapchats and
stuff like you know we don't pile a weed
in front of them and other stuff and I
just go do it you're like you're gonna
go to jail yeah this is out there
someplace you don't smoke weed I'm not
sure that would know I never did know
drink it uh known I don't drink
never know I never did I mean just only
recently in the past like two years I
went
on a vacation with a friend and and and
the deal was okay on vacation I'll try
so I tried a couple of drinks and I just
didn't like it you know like I just
don't like it it's not even about like
being goody-goody or anything like that
I just don't like it
what's your hobby I don't like to I like
to play video games and my heart my
hobby and my work is the same thing I
love going to do stand-up like it's like
things happen to me in life and I have
this thing where I'll go right to the
stage and talk about it you know so I
that's my way I saw you grow there you
know stop tell me more about me you know
it's that my journey that baffles me I
looked at other journeys I looked at
Ralph's remains journey how he's even
sat rest her soul I looked at Mitch
Hedberg journey I look at Doug stay I
still never seen Doug stand up in 96 and
going I'm cancelling this I'm not doing
this ever again cuz I'll never be this
good you just said okay yeah you
Solvency a break yeah for real I just
thought oh I think I just learned I
can't do it how can I do this June of 96
stay at hope was up at the stuff that
the [ __ ] see how on the ground and I
still remember that was his spot too and
I still remember going like I have a
spot too long cancel him with Pat Wilson
hmm and I went camping with my
girlfriend for two days I've really
thought about my life yeah
if I'm gonna do this that's the only way
you're gonna that's the only way I'm
gonna do it I gotta go balls out to the
wall like that he was my first real like
Lenny Bruce and Richard Pryor well when
I saw Stan hoping to see how like I knew
him from Triple R on TV you know he
lived on a triple run that's what got
him really good there's no secret to
that that he backed his car and just one
of the triple one for a year
triple lutz and and karaoke bars so and
drinking and still carrying on and then
he entered the san francisco Comedy
Competition and they were like you know
what his chances are I've even placing
up there zero he's too dirty
and he destroyed them all and the night
of the fun isn't that the file isn't
that the famous one the famous finals it
was him and Dane Cook heaven Dane Cook
and they broke into his car and stole
his clothes so he had to go to a thrift
shop buy a second-hand suit that's why
he dresses the way he does because he
put that suit on and he [ __ ] won the
thing against Dane Cook you know I
didn't it was phenomenal like it was
like did you do any of those did you do
any of those contests I did Seattle I
did Seattle six and then we'll aisha
taylor and Josh wolf and the year I did
it David Crowe one and then San
Francisco I quit the third night you
know it's funny you're just so funny I
did the Seattle competition and when I
finished that I said I am never doing a
competition ever again that is the worst
in three weeks like you know oh the only
thing good about it is is it teaches you
how to showcase it teaches you like
quick stand-up showcase different level
of the game six minutes yeah you're like
boom you got a coming get extra minutes
but after that but just the way what it
did to the comics and then like having
to like roam around for three weeks and
like you have to put yourself up in the
second week I thought I will never
forget I was in what year did you do it
I did it a 2004 and who was it who
defined one at that oh man I don't even
remember man but I remember like you
know you know Siddiqui Fuller
yes Siddiqui was in it you know just
flipping away that year I don't you
remember everybody that was in that and
uh I remember thinking to myself I got
robbed you know what I mean
but whatever Oh Lamar Ferguson Lamont
Ferguson was no I came in six that year
my thing too but I thought I really felt
like it was like I said I just wasn't
some stuff was happening where I was
like come on this isn't what's going on
here
but then I thought it doesn't matter
after what after that I was like I'm
never doing this again and I remember
John Fox was in LA at the em bar doing
showcases and he came up to me and he
was like Erica I'd love for you to be in
San Francisco Comedy Competition
and I said no I'm just like nah I want
to do that and it was crazy to me
because
two years before that that's what I was
that was my goal
how would you go that was my goal that
was my goal was to be in this and then
oh [ __ ] sorry
and then in um then I was like now I
don't I don't want to do this okay so
let me explain this phone
so Erica will break it down to you I did
the Seattle Connelly competition because
I lived in Seattle
I had moved to Seattle to develop
Seattle when I was coming up in comedy
there was a County newspaper that was
run by John Fox and was written by
comics and it was very interesting I
learned a lot in that thing but the back
of it had every club in the country
state-by-state Alabama Arizona you know
Arkansas and I would look at those who
circle the ones and I was going to
perform at and every month and came out
and if you weren't part of like came out
the county works and wits end
it got delivered there for free and
that's how I got turned on to Seattle
that logo just [ __ ] made me go crazy
and I met a stripper in Michigan when I
was on the road she was moving to
Seattle and I said [ __ ] it I'll meet you
up there huh and I had nothing going on
in Colorado she'll end up in jail and I
went up to Seattle and I stayed the
summer and I liked it I liked the calmly
seen up there was Josh wolf it was Brody
Stevens it was a bunch of us up there
[ __ ] around then they asked me do the
contest and I gotta tell you something
for me it was a great experience but I
lived that I don't I don't regret now
Lee in three years yeah
go up there and do it cuz you gonna be a
beat and just stay there for three weeks
three weeks how many shows one weeks you
go oh you because what they do after the
first round the first round you get the
money like they give everybody the last
place money okay I mean so like let's
say the last place pays 500 they give
everyone 500 you know because you know
you could end up being last place of all
you've already been paid that's how they
do it cuz obviously I've never even
looked in tenían and you know look at
the right competitions really interested
me this I for me
it was very interesting I lived in
Seattle so I my first one was a rocky
mountain laughs off by the way I don't
think you ever did that one that was out
of Utah I did the one in Colorado see I
was in in the 90s contests were big now
saying hi Eric big the biggest one was
Johnny Walker national competition they
did the finals on TV oh wow honey walk a
black or Johnny Walker red then the HBO
comedy competition so every said he had
a comedy competition and in the end you
would battle it out and Lake Michigan
somewhere in LA and sometimes they got
Vegas Vegas was where you all went and
did this battle off every [ __ ] year I
when I got into comedy that was
sponsored by Beck's beer it was a Beck's
beer company competition and it was all
of Colorado and you do rules were you
couldn't get paid so the first time I
got on stage was in June and that night
somebody came up to me and goes I have a
gig for you I give you gas money and
I'll never forget when I won the finals
of the Becks Comedy Competition
there was a red flag that I took five
hours for gas the second time I got on
stage and the judges like [ __ ] you he
won hands down I like that one that was
a six-month competition and it was just
people from every every Tuesday see ya
man that's a yeah that's much Seattle
was five nights in a row we six nights
yeah Monday through [ __ ] satellite
yeah you did it and so in your mind and
it wasn't by the way it wasn't just in
Seattle in Seattle it's called the
Seattle copyright yeah yeah you could be
at Everett you could be on the bond the
Billingham up in Bellingham as of Sunday
night but yeah the Bellingham is up what
I learned is what I loved about that
competition is the fact that that was
the first time I performed in front of
like 2,000 people you know that yeah one
of the nights was this kind of casino
gig that was this huge room and it was
like thousands of people in that was the
first time I remember being out there
like oh man this is great it is so you
like it's like so I enjoyed all that but
in the end I was like I'm never doing
this again like I loved all that
experience you know it like it's like
going through boot camp or something
yeah we really nearly boo but I wouldn't
do the [ __ ] again I remember driving
there every night with Josh wolf or but
in my mind like I already thought what
really kills you about Isley is it
teaches you not to size up nothing why
wouldn't I want in there going oh I got
this um I got her I got him I got this
guy coming for real I'll [ __ ] this guy
up in a night Louie this guy can't run
with me some nights it was just somebody
and all sudden there's like a little
black guy yeah you don't even know who
he is you just dismiss him and the first
night God rest his snow his name is
Floyd Jay Phillips I just read recently
he died no bro the first night at that
pizza place in Ballard Washington it was
a Monday night I will never forget this
member I went up there thinking I was
gonna win that whole thing on Monday
night and I came like in 13th and the
guy who ripped that little apart that
night it was Floyd Jay Phillips man I
heard he died that is that is a really
bad news to hear hidden in God rest his
soul yeah very good to me man I have
something I happened dude I did a triple
run with him yeah man I did a triple
room with him where he calls me and he
says he says hey man I want to bring
somebody to be our opener Kuzma at the
time was a two-man show and he goes I
want to bring an emcee but don't worry
he'll stay with me first night we do the
show and then he comes up to me and he's
like yo he's staying with you tonight
and I was like no he's not and we had
this thing where cuz he was like telling
me you shouldn't be co-headlining with
you that's what he told me he was like
you ain't you ain't fun so then that
night I was like okay so we did this
show in like Idaho you know and I went
up and I was like I had that like I was
like oh I'm not good enough okay and I
just I was going for it that night you
know and then he came up we became good
friends after that he's a great you know
because he cuz he came up to me like all
right okay so he took that room apart at
that time he was was great he was though
you lived him like he lived in Portland
yes yes yes
I never knew who he was I never knew
this makes me feel sad and I showed up
with that Monday and destroy he had a
joke about the Portland mall excuse me
security you have you see black people
yeah they're everywhere well I like
something like that he just destroyed
with but I know what you're saying you
would go to these contests you would see
these guys you'd be like your size of
the money yeah yeah but don't judge a
book by it's cover
that's what least I have when they
announce your name thirteen guess what
happens you drive home you don't say a
[ __ ] word your friends think you want
to go eat not really you go home and you
get that notebook and you will stay up
all night yeah man and the next one I
came back in place like third remember
that thing they used to do I don't know
if they did it during your time would be
like this like this extra point from the
audience cheers yes so that was like a
batwing big thing now was like a big
like it's crazy when you get that you
had to get it so it's basically one one
week of every night then another team
comes up dirty comics whatever 15 and
they do that week now if you plays that
week you had to come back the third week
and your crew goes up against his crew
and then the finals well it goes down to
five comics and that's a whole nother
week so it's four weeks of your life but
let me tell you something I learned to
love comics like that's the first time I
was ever involved with a circle of
comedy and a camaraderie day
I'll try Ferris James Inman Floyd Jay
Phillips Josh wolf Gavin Boyd that
contest taught me we went to a Seattle
[ __ ] football game that Sunday like
that somebody gave us a handful of
tickets and we all went together as
comics it taught me a lot it really did
and then I I II should tell you I
started him right he should Taylor
jumping in the pool with a big [ __ ]
titties and [ __ ]
we all went crazy we were like she had a
body of death like that she was just hot
you know and so no it's it's it's an
experience for comics if you've never
done it Eric listen I'm happy we finally
got here on this show all right this is
great I mean we can't I feel like we get
our comedy and no no you forever you're
very insightful on
you take it seriously if not you
wouldn't be where you'd be I am trying
to take it as serious as I can like I
say you should intellectualize it and
then then forget about that stuff and
just do it that's my advice to you yeah
that's it just like Mikey says yes just
do it just do it and you're gonna run
into roadblocks and then you figure them
out
and every time you figure them out it
strengthens you yeah those triple ones
are very [ __ ] that was look Bond Lee
but I still go damn I can't believe I
was doing that you know still booking
yeah you know what I always say
I say I would do triple runs today if
they if it was more professional like if
it was like you could get a good take at
the door and like you spend like five
days in Montana I would do it if you
could leave with a hefty chunk because
you you're doing like these great shows
because that's what great cities man
Bozeman Butte you know
Missoula you could still do that one of
your best friends I know I know flying I
know inside out the car yeah exactly
that do all those towns take a piece of
the door yeah you know book radio triple
told me he didn't want me doing it
anymore and I knew exactly why because
when you get to a certain point where I
knew I just was like you know it was
like you can't have that out there cuz
you can't have these people going cuz
there was some bad like some terrible
terrible so you know you can't have
somebody doing even a little well
because then the people they're gonna be
like wait we need more comics like that
you know that's what you work with so
stops booking you when you get better
you work with Carrboro that's crazy
simple runs are an experience but I pay
you what for some people some headliners
it becomes a reality you've seen it out
there where or cruise ship they have
you're gonna crush it no and I'm not
interested in the meter that's where I
go so [ __ ] forwards down the corner I
did I wanted to check it out I did I saw
I did like four or five I wanted to see
cuz I wasn't in my mind I was thinking
could I end up here and let me see how
it is I did I did I enjoyed my time but
I was like I feel sequestered and I saw
the
and I saw these comics it becomes golden
handcuffs what they do is they they fire
everybody they don't need agents
managers there's 50 ships there's so
much work that they could just dis is it
like I'm gonna do this for the rest of I
can do this for 10 more years save money
you don't spend any money it's like it's
a it's a lame that I thought well let me
check on that Lane and it's listen
comics coming off rises and falls yeah
man I submit this comics in Michigan
that'll take you and me chew us up and
spit us out and they got six kids and a
job and a wife and a job that's too much
insurance that covers it K up and they
can't leave that's the reality of this
way it's 20 [ __ ] comics out there that
will level us one smokes crack and lives
with his mother you know and he can't
you know you know Harlow and George
would [ __ ] what they got rest his
soul he would take calls from a pay
phone on Tuesdays you had to call that
payphone on the book him and he would
only go down and get crack you know that
no follow through is what addicts come
in all sizes and forms and whatever you
want your career to go
it could go that's the choice that you
have yeah I have a choice type I got
until the podcast business ticket
started selling the comedy caught up
because it took 20 years everything to
catch up all those movies I did caught
up you follow me yeah yes play some
they're putting it together they were
like oh such a [ __ ] circle yeah wise
guy once told me this business is a
business of cultures the people who come
here with a quick [ __ ] dream and the
quick it has to happen it don't happen
and if it does happen they don't away I
go to [ __ ] away the guys that eat this
and eat [ __ ] and then later on when
you're doing movies you're like I
remember why I'm getting this you know
why cuz I got a flat on the way from
Bozeman to Billings that time and I had
a [ __ ] that flat yeah I paid my dues
Eric thank you it was great don't forget
to watch I'm dying up here I'm an
episode 1 & 2 I suppose that somebody
said they seen me so I don't [ __ ] on
the episodes you called you in the first
episode for sure yeah very first episode
happy tapping so uh thank you Eric thank
you so much success do not watch the
payaso jammin f
you know when I got back from this [ __ ]
and uh my daddy dates coming up I know
you just have that be special I did not
show time I did it for show time that's
coming out I can't announce the date
they tell me but it's it's coming soon
it'll be on while the store I'm dying
appears on but my next date is coming up
May 24th I'ma be at the Bridgeport
stretch stress factory okay and I'll be
at the factory in Jersey on the 18th or
20th it's sold out and I hope I don't
have to shoot I'm dying appearing cancel
it now you guys know the truth I call
inside so you heard it here Freight in
here first
Donald now you can have people calling
like is it gonna be there is he gonna be
shooting on working out I think a hot
you can check me out Erik Griffin calm
at Erik Griffin with a ke Rik Griffin
that's why I'm Erik Griffin on
everything Instagram Twitter snapchat
and don't forget as usual a shout out to
[ __ ] on it for always being there for
us if you need supplements that a way to
go rustling I can't hook you up with
kettlebells and [ __ ] that's not my
division but as far as the protein
shakes the hemp force the the the alpha
brain the shroom tech all that stuff I
give you a 10% off the liver right the
house and number two are you hiring
posting your position to job sites and
waiting and waiting for the right people
to see it it's never gonna happen
listen you know how hard is they got
great talent and how they the way you go
anyway zip recruiter knew there was a
smaller way so they built the platform
for the right job candidates for you
zipper could have learned what you're
looking for identifies the people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job these invitations have
revolutionized how you find your next
hire in fact 80% of employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day that's
it one day and zip recruiter doesn't
stop there they even spotlight the
strongest application should receive so
you'll never miss a great match the
right candidates are out there
zip recruiter is how to find them do me
a favor I don't care how big your
business is
how small is you could benefit from zip
recruiter okay businesses of all sizes
trust bit as if recruiter for their
hiring needs right now
today the church family gets zip
recruiter for free gratis who gots
nothing you get it for free just go to
zip recruiter Tom slash Church CH you
are CH that zip recruited coms let's
search that CH you are CH zip recruiter
is the smartest way to hire I want to
thank Eric Griffin I want to thank my
man the Flying Jew
and I want to thank you guys for putting
a great week together I love you guys
I'll see you Wednesday stay black stay
strong hit it Lee